Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Happy
New Year, you may have seen the news
about Quicksilver coming back into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe there were a
couple scenes that posted online that
Marvel took down very very quickly
meaning that they're probably real so
I'll explain what was going on during
that but this is huge news so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing the new infinity saga box set
giveaway I'll also explain that at the
end of the video - so late last night a
whole bunch of clips for two twin boys
performing as Wiccan and speed scarlet
which envisions children for the
upcoming one division and Doctor Strange
- posted online I made sure to download
them before Marvel took them down of
course but because of the hard core
rules that YouTube has about putting
little kids in your videos I can't
actually put them in the video here so
I'll explain what they were talking
about what the scenes were and what it
all means last year a couple casting
breakdowns revealed that they were
planning on doing scarlet which
envisions comic-book children during the
wand division series so it's not a huge
surprise that the actual children are
showing up but it's what they're talking
about what they're doing in the scenes
that implies that Quicksilver is also
coming back as part of all this
craziness one of the little kids is
named Tommy and he's talking to another
little kid presumably his twin brother
called Billy
so Tommy is the name of speed in the
comics Billy is the name of Billy Kaplan
Wiccan in the comics I think they're
going to be changing their backstories a
little bit for the purposes of Wandavision in Doctor Strange - and possibly
future Young Avengers stuff so I'll
explain that stuff in a second it's not
quite as important as what they're
actually doing during these scenes so
Tommy is talking to Billy and they're
really afraid to go disturb their quote
unquote uncle who's sleeping on scarlet
which envisions living room couch late
into the morning they dare each other to
go wake him up but they never refer to
him as anything more than their uncle in
the important thing about Scarlet Witch
and vision is that vision doesn't have
any biological family I mean obviously
we're doing the twins from the comics
I'll explain how that works in a second
because technically he can't have
biological children there's a really
crazy comic book explainer for that but
Scarlet Witch does have a brother who
would be these little boys uncle so
that's why everyone is taking this to
mean that whatever
chaos magic alternate reality multiverse
way that they're using to explain how
Scarlet Witch is physically capable of
having biological children with vision
they're also using that same way to
explain how they can bring back
Quicksilver when we saw him die during
Avengers age of Ultron you also remember
that Doctor strange too is called the
multiverse of madness in Agatha Harkness
is supposed to be one of the characters
on the Wandavision series played by Kathryn Hahn
she's a very powerful sorceress from the
comics who's had a very contentious
relationship with Scarlet Witch in the
past Kevin Feige said that they were
using Wandavision to turn Wanda of the
MCU into the true Scarlet Witch version
of her character from the comics and he
flat out just said that she's the new
most powerful character after avengers
endgame in that video that I posted
yesterday so the most logical
explanations for this is she could
either be living out her fantasy life
that she creates for herself with vision
like the twins maybe Quicksilver in an
alternate reality or they could go the
full Chaos magic route either way the implication is that when
she does create this fantasy reality for
herself as they've been hyping up for
the Wandavision series
it has far-reaching consequences and
that's why Doctor Strange gets involved
in why she winds up crossing over into
Doctor Strange to imagine what he would
do if he found out that Scarlet Witch
created an alternate reality in that
alternate reality started to spill into
our main reality there's that funny clip
from Avengers infinity war where Doctor
Strange is having his big bro off moment
with Iron Man and tells him exactly what
his main job is sorcerer supreme is this
still maybe the best chance we have
against that is so converse they may
also be his best chance against us so if
we don't do our jobs what is your job
exactly besides making balloon animals
protecting your reality so when I say
that scarlet witch's fake reality might
be causing problems for the main reality
that will probably have something to do
with the main villain of Doctor Strange
too because it sounds like Wandavision
is one part then doing the Tom King
vision run with some changes letting
Scarlet Witch spend a few hot minutes in
the perfect life she imagined for
herself envisioned in their potential
children that she always wanted for
herself but never got a chance to have
then the second part of the series is
her being upgraded to comic book Scarlet
Witch chaos magical level powerful is
that fake reality starts to crack and
crumble around her
during the tonking vision run they kind
of did a version of this with visions
character Scarlet Witch isn't a big part
of it because he creates a separate
synthezoid family for himself but it all
just goes completely to hell by the end
of it but if they are bringing back
Quicksilver during Wandavision as part
of this fake reality it might only be
for a few hot minutes I don't know if
they have any plans to let some of her
fake reality stick eventually going
forward into the future because there
are a lot of people that think that
Kevin Feige is also using this series to
introduce Wiccan and speed so that they
can go off into a young Avengers team-up
they are core original founding members
of the first Young Avengers comic book
team the video clips we saw were for
little kids though but the casting
breakdowns that we got last year that
said that they were trying to do Scarlet
Witch and visions children talked about
kids that would age rapidly that would
be a really easy way to explain how they
can be born and then within the span of
a few years be old enough for a young
Avengers team-up but it's not clear how
much of this Wandavision stuff is going to
show up during Doctor Strange 2 or if
they'll just have some quick montage and
some references to the events of Wandavision and all that craziness during the
beginning of Doctor Strange too for some
context because you have to imagine
there's always that one person that just
completely ignores everything that
Marvel does and then they see a big
movie they go to see it and they have no
idea how Scarlet Witch got so powerful
at the beginning of it after avengers
endgame wait a minute where did she
learn to do chaos magic where did that
happen remember how they just announced the Wandavision was coming out later at
the end of this year instead of waiting
until 2021 to release it one of the big
reasons I think they're doing that is
because they're probably going to release
the first big trailer for Doctor Strange
2 at the end of this year Scarlet Witch
is going to show up in it looking very
different being super powerful Marvel
wants people to understand why that is
so that's why you need the Wandavision
series to explain how all this crazy
stuff starts happening I know a lot of
you outside the United States are like
wait a minute
I can't even watch the Wandavision show
because they don't have Disney Plus in
my country most of the countries around
the world will have Disney Plus by the
time all this Marvel stuff starts airing
in the fall first is going to be Falcon
and Winter Soldier which will start
sometime in August or September that'll
run all their episodes then they'll do
all the wan division episodes then
they'll do the mandalorian season two
but while all that's happening they'll
start dropping clips and trailers
or Doctor Strange to a lot of you are also
asking if they're using the concept of
scarlet which envisions children on the
series to introduce the concept of
mutants formally into the MCU the x-men
characters and I think it's a little
more complicated than that because of
their crazy back story in the comics so
I think the way they're going to play it is
going to be a little more subtle in the
real x-men mainstream a less characters
like Wolverine the core x-men characters
you'll see pop up in a separate film one
division will probably just be the back
door to that stuff so you'll say that
there's some Easter eggs and references
in there setting up that down the road
laying seeds you also remember the
famous conversation that Kevin Feige had
at comic-con where he said that each of
the new projects during phase four the
movies the TV shows will lay seeds for
the big stuff that's coming later on
that includes bringing the x-men
characters into the MCU that's part of
the reason why Kevin Feige now controls
all of Marvel television shows and the
movies and the comics so that it all
works together and you have seeds of
everything laid in each different
project so that all connects together
does face for start to plant the seeds
for whatever we're going to see because we
obviously saw than us the whole infinity
saga the seeds were planted way early on
yes we debated what we should announce
today should we announce four and five
we've planned them out we've got five
years down the road and I was like I
think you 11 projects in two years is
plenty it's still not super clear who
the main villain of Doctor Strange 2 is
going to be but it does sound like it's
going to be someone as big if not bigger
than Dormammu so right now it kind of
seems like Agatha Harkness might wind up
being the secret backdoor villain of one
division she's not a big enough
character to be the main villain of
Doctor Strange 2 so it sounds like
Scarlet Witch and Agatha Harkness cause
a whole bunch of problems for our
reality during Wandavision and then
that creates an opportunity for the main
villain of Doctor Strange to to come
into our reality which is where Doctor
Strange gets involved protecting our
reality let me know in the comments
though do you think that Scarlet Witch
envisions children talking about their
uncle scarlet witch's brother implies
that they're bringing back Quicksilver
for Wandavision and who do you think
the main villain of Doctor Strange 2 is
going to wind up being do you think it's
going to be nightmare or do you think
that it's going to be Mephisto
because even though everything is
pointing to it not being Mephisto
Mephisto is a core part of the origin
story of Scarlet Witch envisions
children they originally start out as
the soul shards that Mephisto then
reabsorbs into himself but then because
they're so powerful they get
reincarnated into other bodies of wicken
in speed so that's how scarlet witch's
children in the comics are actually born
technically to other people around the
United States and she doesn't learn
about it till later if you haven't read
any of those comics and you think that
sounds really confusing don't worry the
version of all that stuff that they do
on the TV shows will be very very
different like I said we're doing the new infinity
saga box set giveaway I have a second
one to giveaway I'll leave that open
until Black Widow comes out in the
spring
everyone click here for that new Doctor
Strange video where Kevin Feige talks
about how Scarlet Witch is the new most
powerful character and click here for my
brand new Marvel Deadpool 3 video thank
you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome, Happy New Year!